[Music]
so in uh thailand
they're dealing with a bout of flooding
uh which happens sometimes uh so a
restaurant owner who owns a business
like next to one of the rivers where
they were experiencing flooding he's
like oh man
like this could probably end my business
because it floods so bad that it it gets
like four feet of water in his business
going all the way through the damn ring
four foot of water yep so he's like he
has to canoe to his [ __ ] customers
and [ __ ]
yep but
what he did
instead of instead of canoeing to his
customers
he had another idea he's like wait maybe
people will like the experience of
dining like partially it's a restaurant
yeah it's a restaurant so he's like they
like that natural disaster feeling yeah
yeah eating yeah like with a dead body
going by
oh [ __ ] people must love that anaconda
[Laughter]
no so he um
he's like i'm just gonna try it out and
it's actually becoming a huge a huge
success people people like sitting
partially in the water
oh
that's just a little bit in the water
that's like a vegas bar or pool this
[ __ ] is like booked out the ass no way
people want to do it there's a lot of
tourists or locals locals who love a
gimmick
i mean it's just it's just like tables
on the on the river
i didn't know it's four feet i thought
four feet of water is like you'll be
submerged i thought they were gonna be
like here [ __ ] eating food maybe
their chairs are really tall
i don't know about water looking like
that though oh you mean like they're
like the booths yeah like in those like
stilt chairs yeah yeah like a barber
yeah how do you think it smells in that
water dookie well i think it's moving
right or i don't know yeah that smells
bad river water
on the one end it's cool on the other
end it's like not necessary well the
water looks great
that's that's muddy water
did something similar to that uh there's
a little
somebody bleached those waters yeah oh
that's crazy that looks a little too
intense man yeah sometimes it just kind
of floods real quick
oh that's dangerous dude but he says the
customers love it that is yeah that's
gotta be cool
this is like rainforest cafe off the
[ __ ] chain right this is the
rainforest guys they should call it i
did something similar to this but it's
not that high um in norcal well on the
way there's this place and um [ __ ]
damn big sur there's a restaurant where
you can get your stuff
and
you get in the cooler like it's a cool
little red cooler right and then you
take it down to the river and there's
chairs and tables there oh that's dope
yeah it's really [ __ ] sick and then
you can just have a picnic on the river
and the river's like about half a foot
or so so yeah it's pretty cool that's
really cool but yeah it's not it's much
nicer looking than this it's on purpose
it was intentional
i do think it would be fun
you know what i mean like you would
remember it yeah the food was okay you
would remember the experience if if i
planned on going to that place and i got
there and it was full of water
but he was still serving people i'd be
like you want to just do it [ __ ] it but
i would not be like yo we got the water
place
they have an opening let's book it
let's make reservations the water place
the flooded restaurant
like it's just like they're gonna have
pruning toes the entire time you know
what i'm saying like your nails are all
[ __ ]
you might have catfish
you might have catfish nibbling on your
toes oh yeah that's nice some people
like that yeah little you know
exfoliating fish skins yeah that's
popular in thailand don't they do that
in thailand southeast asia yeah i think
so
i've seen it somewhere i forgot why it's
easier to clean you probably go like
this
are you dancing okay
[Laughter]
same with the please
with the dishes you just pick it up from
the water you just drop it you just dip
it and then you put it back on the
[ __ ] you need to take a piss you just
turn over so this is the parking lot
[Laughter]
you just pull right in
a lot of parking they said yo why that
dude's trunk open yeah
go get something from his trunk you
should have closed this sweater in there
you gotta go back they put their shoes
in there like honey i love that the
theme comes all the way out to the
parking lot
this is a very thorough business it's
just like disneyland the mickey mouse
starts in the parking lot
that's [ __ ] hilarious you have to pay
for parking
there's a valet dude it's pretty
expensive how do you even have a car
you're like
[ __ ]
you have to look away the truck is over
with your little heads
there's a pressure dude you gotta wind
down the window he's like waiter can i
get a glass of water yeah
sure can use out to you
so yeah that's pretty confusing well at
least if the water was clear or blue i
think i'd be down but not if it just
looked like a buddies
water
that [ __ ] looks like
sewer it's pretty bad
i've seen water in a gutter look clearer
than that that's true
so like before he had a restaurant there
right and then obviously it was probably
a dry restaurant and then flooding
happened right so does that mean it just
stays flooded always now or is it just
like when it's no longer a flooding
moment now it's just like there's like
[ __ ] dirty ass yucky mud water it's
like a flapping catfish on the ground
i'm saying this is like dead [ __ ]
everywhere it's like seaweeds this is a
shot from happy hour
oh my gosh
during the dry time why not do it with
the baby not allowed in the boat
i know right well he's headed in 21 and
over bro
[Laughter]
[Music]
remember when there was a
there was like a hurricane and and um
there was like a whole flooding thing
that happened recently right like years
ago
um there was this meme that was going
around there was no meme but it was like
it was like we don't discriminate who we
rescue and it was like it had asian
black mexican and a [ __ ] dog i was
like what the [ __ ]
where was this
and i was like why
i like the idea of a dog racist i know
right like what why is a dog it's like
you're including a dog with minorities
and shits like we don't discriminate we
save everyone
it's fun
[ __ ]
fun for the whole family
oh
yeah they're all headed up oh it's the
dog we're all headed down that looks
like a good like universal studios ride
yo yeah dude that reminds me of this one
video i saw during that whole flood
family emergency there was a car the
family the lady was going down um in the
flood like that she was she was going in
her car and then she like she that whole
car was submerging she couldn't get out
and his dude [ __ ]
jumped in the water [ __ ] went under
pulled the door and then got her out wow
that's sick i know i was like that's
crazy is that part of the family
emergency rider
did you did you watch cop land
coughlin toplane that sounds familiar
what happened in cop land dude
stallone like saved this chick and then
he [ __ ] up his hearing for the rest of
his life oh yeah it's a key point in the
movie he just had to get out part of his
character yeah he didn't he didn't know
how to shake it up
there's this class i want to take it's
um
it's like a submerged aircraft class
it's pretty tight so it's like a part of
a uh it's part of like a airplane with
seats and stuff and it's like what do
you do if your aircraft goes underwater
and so it goes you it puts you under
water and it spins upside down like
three times and then you have to like
get out here's what you do when your
craft goes underwater you die
that's a cool class what is this
imagine like a nasa-sized pool where
they do like those type of things oh
that's cool yeah it's like uh where did
you look this up i just googled that
[ __ ] like emergency water or like water
crisis survival i was waiting for steve
to say something dude yeah so what
happens when you don't know what to do
you die oh cool yeah i think it's it'd
be fun find a way it'd be fine yeah it'd
be fine if they put you under water they
spin you around and now you got to
figure out okay my seatbelt stuck how do
i get out of it how do i you know like
where i'm disoriented why are you
holding your breath yeah yeah yeah how
long can they hold their breath for in
there because what if you don't need air
is there a guy with a scuba gear that
has one of these and then they put it in
your mouth and you go
okay the instructors the truck was it
one of those things where like the water
starts to flow inside of the cabin or
whatever and then you got to like swim
up to the top oh that's pretty cool too
i don't know if they have that kind of
that's sick but then you look to the
next guy and you [ __ ] mouth them out
and try to push some oxygen over and
[ __ ] yeah
that's what i always wanted i wonder
what a whatever you think that works
though when you get the air from the top
and you exhale into their mouth isn't
that a lot of co2 you just can't heal
it's a lot but there's still oxygen
but would a homophobe accept someone
else's air
hell yeah dude
i mean if if they could go up why can't
i go up and get errors like let's say i
hate gays yeah
and then you're like i'll save your life
i think that guy dies he's like i'm not
gay dude i'm not gay don't give me
that's gonna kiss me and then he dies
but he can't say that underwater yeah
pushing for the last two inches the last
two inches they're like you want some
air and you're like nah
yeah
no you know what i'm doing
if i was in that situation and we're
about to drown i would turn the guy and
he's like hey you want my oxygen i'm
like are you gay yeah
yeah you died let me i'm gonna need to
know if you're gay or not
because you are huh
only bart would look at this and go that
looks like fun
what are you talking about i want to
train he's not googling for a class he's
like i want to be a part of that i want
to do that people take yoga
this guy's looking for this kind of
class when i look at the emergency like
[ __ ] pamphlet or there's like a giant
water slide that looks pretty tight oh
hey you could watch a plane crash happen
um this dude recorded all on his gopro
and it was a small plane that went down
in hawaii yeah and then they went uh
they landed in the water and then you
see the whole thing he was recording it
it was pretty crazy really
that would just swam to shore
probably michael he was like some kind
of [ __ ] collegiate swimmer yeah he's
come kind of like swimming
he just leaves his wife
a lady died
yeah one lady died yeah because she but
she she looked like she couldn't move or
anything
when she landed [ __ ] when did this
happen no she looked good she looked
very healthy and fine and then all of a
sudden like she died i'm like oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
have you seen this video i want to see
y'all it's pretty crazy when did it
happen
several years ago yeah several years ago
they literally just take off and then
they land
go pro
everyone's pretty calm too there's like
six people or whatever
he's still in his seat it's known
rushing the that that was too busy
[ __ ] trying to go viral with his
gopro he didn't even
know he didn't even get his [ __ ] ready
dude
they should have had their [ __ ] life
vests on
because you gotta blow it up and [ __ ]
don't you [ __ ] i would have been
blowing it up while i was going down you
might have to blow it up on the exit
because if everyone's puffed up you
might cause a traffic jam
oh damn see the water coming through the
door right there that's gotta be [ __ ]
crazy yeah that's [ __ ] crazy as [ __ ]
oh dude i have my phone like this
thank god it's hawaii though right
because it's like warm water and [ __ ]
now it looks like a vacation yeah this
is the class that bar wants to take damn
yeah airplane damn and the lady died
yeah one of those people died and they
looked everyone looks fine but i guess
it was hard she was old yeah the one
that died she was old oh that's a small
plane you have to tread a lot of water
for a while yeah
it was like an eight meter six seater
i don't know that she had hers on i
don't know
it's weird that is crazy yeah that's
crazy but everyone like you'll see the
plane slowly going down and everyone
kind of does their own thing like some
some guy just swam off the shore some
people are kind of huddled together
whatever yeah
it's pretty crazy like that the whole
way go over and i would be i would be
talking into it like all right guys i'm
over here
make sure you subscribe
yeah that experience and [ __ ] you know
that's because that's instagram what are
you doing you have to dance while you're
doing it no no joe would be telling pat
he's like hey pat edit that part out
where i screamed okay
cool cool cool yeah all right here we go
he's on he's like hey dude follow my
challenge it's the uh crash in the
hawaii ocean challenge
crash and try to live
[Laughter]
if you like this crash like this video
i'll see you in another crash
[Music]